ALL.
BRET.
>> Bret: JUST OUTSIDE IN
DOWNTOWN SEATTLE.
THE FBI IS INVESTIGATING A NOOSE
IN THE GARAGE OF NASCAR’S ONLY
AFRICANAFRICAN-AMERICAN DRIVER.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN HAS THE
DETAILS.
>> IT WAS A PART OF POWERFUL SYM
IT WAS ALL IN SUPPORT OF NASCAR
DRIVER, THE SPORT’S LOAN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN DRIVER WHOSE
GARAGE WAS A SCENE OF A
DESPICABLE ACTS ON SUNDAY.
A NOOSE.
A REMINDER OF A VIOLENT AND
FORGETTABLE PAST ETCHED INTO
AMERICA’S FABRIC.
THAT WAS FOUND BY A MEMBER OF
HIS TEAM JUST HOURS AFTER
SOMEONE FLEW A CONFEDERATE FLAG
TO PROTEST NASCAR BANNING THE
SYMBOL AT ALL EVENTS.
AND WHILE VIEWS ON THE FLAG
ISSUE, SUPPORT FOR HIM IN THE
WAKE OF A NOOSE INCIDENT WAS
RESOUNDING.
SEVEN-TIME NATIONAL CHAMPION
KNOWN AS THE KING SAYS THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO PLACE IN OUR SPORT
OR SOCIETY FOR RACISM ADDING
THAT THIS GUILTY ACT SERVES AS A
REMINDER OF HOW FAR WE STILL
HAVE TO GO.
LeBRON JAMES TWEETED HIS
SUPPORT.
"I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW PROUD I
AM OF YOU FOR CONTINUING TO TAKE
A STANCE ON CHANGE HERE IN
AMERICA AND IN SPORTS."
HE HAS CREATED SOME CONTROVERSY
WITH NASCAR FANS THANKS TO HIS
SUPPORT OF THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER MOVEMENT.
TO BE CLEAR, WHILE THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING, THERE IS STILL
MUCH WE DON’T KNOW ABOUT WHAT IS
ALLEGED TO HAVE HAPPENED,
INCLUDING WHAT DID SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS CAPTURE AND WHO HAD
ACCESS OR OPPORTUNITY?
IT’S ALL PART OF A INCREASINGLY
COMPLICATED PORTRAIT OF A
COUNTRY REEXAM NEEDING ITS PAST
FUTU.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT IS NOW ON CUE TO
BE REMOVED OVER RACISM AND
IMPERIALISM.
HE SAID I HOPE THAT BOB IS
FEELING LOVED AND SUPPORTED.